rock paper scissors is an improved
information game
um right because you don't know what I'm
about to throw I do but yeah usually not
yeah yeah and so you can't just say like
oh I'm just gonna throw a rock every
single time because the other person's
gonna figure that out and notice a
pattern and then suddenly you're going
to start losing and so you don't just
have to figure out like which action to
play you have to figure out the
probability that you play it and really
importantly the value of an action
depends on the probability that you're
going to play it so if you're playing
Rock every single time that value is
really low but if you're never playing
rock you play Rock like one percent of
the time then suddenly the the other
person's probably gonna be throwing
scissors and when you throw rock the
value of that action is going to be
really high
now you take that to Poker what that
means is
the value of bluffing for example if
you're the kind of person that never
Bluffs and you have this reputation as
somebody that never Bluffs and suddenly
you Bluff there's a really good chance
that that bluff is going to work and
you're gonna make a lot of money
on the other hand if you've got a
reputation like if they've seen you play
for a long time and they see oh you're
the kind of person that's bluffing all
the time
when you Bluff they're not going to buy
it and they're going to call you down
you're going to lose a lot of money
and that
finding that balance of how often you
should be bluffing is uh the key
challenge of a game of poker
and um you contrast that with a game
like chess
it doesn't matter if you're opening with
the Queen's Gambit 10 of the time or 100
of the time the value the expected value
is the same
so um so that's that's why we need these
algorithms that understand not just we
have to figure out what actions are good
but the probabilities we need to get the
exact probabilities correct and that's
actually when we created the bot
labradus libratus means balanced because
the algorithm that we designed was
designed to find that right balance of
how often it should play each action the
balance of how often in the key sort of
branching is the bluff or not the bluff
is that a is that a good crude
simplification of the major decision in
poker it's a good simplification I think
that's like the main tension but it's
it's not just how often to Bluff or not
to Bluff it's like how often should you
bet in general how often should you what
what kind of bet should you make
um should you bet big or should you bet
small and with which with with which
hands uh and so this is where the idea
of a range comes from because when you
are bluffing with a particular hand in a
particular spot
you don't want there to be a pattern for
the other person to pick up on you don't
want them to figure out oh whenever this
person is in this spot they're always
bluffing and so you have to reason about
okay would I also bet with a good hand
in this spot
you want to be unpredictable so you have
to think about what would I do if I had
this different set of cards is there
explicit estimation of like a theory of
mind that the other person has about you
or is that just a emergent thing that
happens
the way that the Bots handle it that are
really successful they have an explicit
theory of mind so they're explicitly
reasoning about what are what's the
common knowledge belief what does what
do you think I have what do I think you
have what do you think I think you have
um it's explicitly reasoning about that
is there multiple U's there so
maybe that's jumping ahead to six
players but is there a stickiness to the
person so it's an iterative game you're
playing the same person
there is there's a stickiness to that
right you're gathering information as
you play it's not every every
um every hand is in your hand is there
um a continuation in terms of estimating
what kind of player I'm facing here
that's a good question so
you could approach the game that way the
way that the Bots do it they don't and
the way that humans approach it also
expert human players the way they
approach it is to basically assume that
you know my strategy so
I'm going to try to pick a strategy
where even if I were to play it for 10
000 hands and you could figure out
exactly what it was you still wouldn't
be able to beat it basically what that
means is I'm trying to approximate the
Nash equilibrium I'm trying to be
perfectly balanced because if if I'm
playing the national equilibrium even if
you know what my strategy is like I said
I'm still unbeatable in expectation so
so that's what that's what the bot aims
for and that's actually what a lot of
expert poker players aim for as well to
start by playing the Nash equilibrium
and then maybe if they spot weaknesses
in the way you're playing then they can
deviate a little bit to take advantage
of that